las mujeres se convirtieron en
luchadoras Así que las vestí con
armadura
con nuevas técnicas y formas innovadoras
Así es como Paco rabanne imaginó la alta
costura un entorno en el que se hizo un
nombre gracias a su visión vanguardista
y sus elecciones Audaces
trabajo con materiales extraños no voy a
lugares normales que ofrecen alta
costura voy a los talleres en las
fábricas los laboratorios los lugares
más extraños del mundo para tratar de
encontrar nuevos materiales un material
creaciones que le valieron a este
inmigrante español el sobrenombre de
metalúrgico de la moda engalanado por
Coco Chanel su verdadero nombre es
Francisco rabanneda y Cuervo huyo de la
Guerra Civil Española con su madre a la
edad de 5 años para instalarse en
Bretaña después de estudiar arquitectura
se dedicó a la moda y lanzó la marca
Paco rabanne en 1966 sus vestidos que
recordaban la cota de Maya su modernidad
sedujeron a las estrellas del momento
como françois James bar o incluso
nunca dejó de inventar modelos
fluorescentes en plástico moldeado y
diversificados en perfumería y petapocté
el éxito estaba en camino junto con ipsa
Logan fue uno de los primeros
diseñadores en trabajar con modelos
afros en las pasarelas pero en 1999 sus
fantasiosas predicciones sobre la caída
de la estación mir provocaron muchas
burlas en su contra
destellos cuando llegué a París de gente
quemándose hasta morir gritando que
tenía que taparme los oídos esta imagen
me persiguió durante mucho tiempo y
estudié Las profecías para encontrar que
todas las profecías decían que un día la
capital de los árboles jóvenes se
quemaría
una declaración que marca un punto de
inflexión en su carrera en el año 2000
Deja los desfiles Y se retira
definitivamente de la moda para
dedicarse a otras actividades la marca
sigue vivo Paco rabanne murió en Bretaña
a la edad de 88 años